um let's go to noah from fort lauderdale
noah what is how are things down there
the the craziness was just getting going
when i left miami about a month and a
half ago oh mr pacman you have no idea
it's crazy
i would almost go as far to say as
diluted deluded or diluted
whichever works okay good either maybe
both yeah what's going on
um i uh i had a question about the um
so i was never really a political guy
until covid hit
and when kovitt hit i started
essentially studying
right wing media because i knew the
circus was going to be great
um i'm curious to know about if you if
you have a connection
or at least a connection that i drew
about uh like right-wing
agitation about kamala uh campaigning
for newsome
over trump campaigning for roy moore
so if so is there an analogy between the
two yeah i uh i i think there is where a
lot of republicans would support roy
moore after all of the insane
allegations
but now there's
even more outrage
that kamala is campaigning for newsom
oh i see so you're you're saying is it
possible that kamala harris's support of
newsome will hurt newsom
yes
i i mean it's really just it's an
empirical question
nationally kamala harris is not polling
very well
my guess is
that in blue states she's polling better
and that in her home state of california
she's polling even better
i
my guess is that the numbers have been
looked at by the newsom campaign and
they've made the call that it's it's
better for her to help but i understand
the concept if people don't like her
they might be turned off but here's the
thing
if you kind of like knew some but you
don't like kamala
i don't think that her campaigning makes
you go vote for larry elder you know so
so i'm not hugely concerned about that
well my
my big concern is um
like i said i've essentially been
studying right wing media and
um
i'm sure you're familiar with candace
owens of course
um have you seen that she's put out a
statement essentially saying
that a national divorce is inevitable
you mean like a like the country
splitting into two countries
yes oh i don't care what she says i
don't know that she's ever been right
about anything and she's one of the
biggest feminists i know so i i couldn't
kind of see what she says yeah
okay yeah uh
thank you mr pacman uh long time
listener first time caller uh got a lot
of respect for you in the show thank you
all right stay safe in florida it sounds
crazy down there oh no promises all
right very good
um
let's see who else we could chat with
today because there are so many people
that want to get on today
let's try um
let's go to greg peach greg peach you're
on the air
hi david
um
so i'm actually i've been on in queue
for a while and you took a break um and
i was just really surprised because it
lasted like less than five seconds um
why did you need to take such a small
break i would think you'd need like at
least five to ten minutes for a
substantial break yeah no that's true i
like to keep the brakes very short and
by the way are you running a lathe in
the background
oh you can actually okay shoot you got
me david my my audio's not perfect
i'm sorry
all right did you have a question today
um i i guess yeah i had a real question
have you ever considered uh like writing
books um like tom hartman he's written a
lot of books
you know i have i'm currently in
discussion now uh about a book and the
question with the book is what is the
book about you know so i want to make
sure i'm doing something like i don't
want to just throw together a book in a
month like some people have done and
it's sort of like of no value whatsoever
um but i do i am i am currently
exploring different ideas and treatments
for a book
okay sounds great thank you now are you
willing to tell me what is the power
tool that's running in the background
uh it's a it's an air filter i um
i just picked one up because i was
worried i'd get allergies i haven't had
problems with that and i just leave it
running all the time for like better air
quality okay do you feel that your
allergies are better with it on
yeah i think it works good
good all right thank you so much for the
call
yeah
all right well
uh sort of a
slow deceleration on the calls today but
i do appreciate everybody i was able to
speak to
and i look forward to speaking to more
people again
next time we take calls we'll go to a
break and be back right after this